IRL will be live in Miami with Patrick
Bet David Donald Trump Jr Matt Gates and
Luke rowski join us there get your
tickets by clicking the link in the
description below or by going to
timcast.net
because of his speech he was on the
capital grounds he did not go in the
building his charges are like
misdemeanor trespass of some sort they
want him to go to jail prison federal
prison for three months and the the fact
the factors in the sentencing guideline
recommendations were his speech before
during and after
shocking when I read what what his
response was I thought it was uh uh very
important considering what's going on
let me read for you from timcast.net
the judge overseeing is sentencing to go
against the recommendation submitted by
the Department of Justice while in DC sh
told the crowd of people over a bullhorn
the Democrats are posing as Communists
but we know what they really are they're
just tyrants they're tyrants and so
today on January 6 we declare death to
tyranny death to tyrants the doj asked
the court to consider that Shroyer's
conduct on January 6 like the conduct of
hundred of other riers took place in the
context of a large and violent Riot that
relied on numbers to O who to
overwhelmed uh oh tyo the police
officers who were trying to prevent to
breach the capital
building all right so here's here's
where it gets good in the response to
the government's proposed sentence
Shroyer's attorneys argue the
prosecution is taking direct aim at
freedom of speech quote it seeks to
penalize Mr Shroyer for his viewpoints
claiming apparently that his views are
relevant offenses offense conduct that
must be considered in crafting a
sentence sufficient but not greater than
necessary to punish the crime to which
Mr Shroyer pleaded guilty a single
misdemeanor count of entering and
remaining in a restricted building or
grounds in violation of 18 USC section
1752 A1 says the responding statement
from Shroyer's team that says it all
what was Shroyer charged with being in a
restricted
area that's it and for this they drafted
up this this recommendation saying his
speech on his show said the election was
stolen that he hates tyranny so he needs
three months since hold on hold on what
was he charged with Insurrection was he
charged with incitement no he was
charged with effectively trespass so in
what way is it relevant it's because
these people are are cultists it's
entirely
political and I think this is another uh
uh uh another grain of sand in the Heap
of evidence we know that what they're
doing to the January 6 uh uh individuals
not all of them but many of them and if
not the majority of them and people like
Owen Shroyer and Donald Trump and these
others is political persecution through
prosecution for political
power I think you're right I think uh
Shroyer's experience is really
interesting because there's obviously
antipathy on on the part of the
government they they want him to be yet
another person who is dangerous and
therefore needs to be locked up and I
think ultimately it's really interesting
he's being represented by uh Norm pattis
who also represented Joe bigs and um and
Zack reels if I'm not mistaken uh
these are very different cases obviously
the proud boys were charged with sedici
conspiracy and you can argue if that was
fair or right or not uh but in this case
he never entered the building he stood
outside and yelled a bunch of stuff and
they are saying therefore he deserves to
go to jail on this charge it it seems
like they will never let this Panic that
they manufactured die it's a totally
manufactured panic and it's interesting
too because um a lot of the January 6
people who have already been arrested
detained prosecuted charged sentenced
were like the little people the people
whose names you don't know you know like
the grandmas from Illinois or whatever
who now don't really get a hearing you
saw sometimes they would come on Tucker
Carlson's show on Fox and they would
talk about it and they would talk about
what's going on with them but they were
you know they were people whose names
you didn't know and now they're using
all of the precedents all of the like
heavy handed um prosecution that they
staged against these smaller people who
you didn't know whose only really Julie
Kelly was following you know and they're
using those same preced to go after
people whose names you do know and
they're going to use those same
precedents that they're doing now
against Shroyer and the proud boys and
all of those guys to go after Trump
because it's the same judge yeah I mean
chukin is the same judge and Chen hates
Trump has said that has her own opinions
and then they're using all of this too
to try and get Trump off the ballot and
I think it's very important to note that
no one has been charged with
Insurrection like that's not if you go
to a search it's just not there in the
in the in the doj documents of people
charged with um you know January 6th
stuff I want to jump to the statement
the doj made in their quote when they
said that uh uh they have to consider
that sh's conduct like the conduct of
hundreds of other Riders took place in
the context of a large and violent Riot
Heavens Me Owen Shroyer yelled death to
tyrants shocking wow I'm I I I wonder
how much prison time RS is going to get
for for literally telling people to go
into the capital and then being there
right when the barricade was torn down
and they gave Joe bigs 20 years so
Rays what's he going to get 50 life he
gonna get nothing you already saw the
Washington Post the New York Times and
everybody else coming out saying like
Rays did nothing wrong it's literally
everybody else who did something wrong
even though we have video one he's the
one guy that we have seen do you know
doing the thing but somehow he's defens
I I think it's interesting too like the
cops that gave um the shaman a a tour
around the capital I haven't heard
anything about disciplinary action
happening for them right like there is
no Fallout for people who you know
whether we can say it was mistaken or on
purpose facilitated actual things that
then people were sent toil who shot an
unarmed woman nothing and that's crazy I
think your point that they have been
building up to this for so long it's so
interesting because often when I'm
writing these stories the St the the
statement comes across and it's from the
doj that uh over a thousand people have
been charged in connection with January
6 over 600 have been sentenced and over
300 are in prison at this moment and
when I read that sentence I am horrified
right I I feel that way because I
obviously have one I have a a a
perspective on January 6 that you know
leftwing mainstream media doesn't when
they hear the same statistics that over
a thousand people are have been charged
that over 600 people have been sentenced
and that over 300 are in jail they think
good job we're getting them but it's so
insane like in Portland in the summer of
2020 they rided for over a 100 nights
straight they tried to burn down a
federal courthouse Donald Trump was like
we really should send in National Guard
and the governor was like no no we hate
you don't send in the National Guard we
would rather have our Courthouse burned
down you know they tried to set fire to
the mayor's apartment building while
there were people in it yeah and this is
all totally fine and then we hit January
you know 6th 2021 they call it this they
call it deadly riots it was literally
one day it was one day deadly Riot
caused by the police officer right also
where everyone went home by like what 8
right it was literally one day and they
talk about you know people brought
weapons there were what tasers and a
fire extinguisher I I love how they also
say like they they say oh there's no way
that they would have been able to
overthrow anything don't they understand
how this government thing works like you
can't just take the building and
overthrow everything and at the same
time they act like that's what would
have happen and today there were leftist
agitators occupying house Speaker Kevin
McCarthy's office why are they not going
to jail for 25,000 years I think you
meant insurrectionists
insurrectionists we we always are going
back and forth over what words to use
for these people what those people were
doing at Kevin McCarthy's office just
straight up on the table is that legal I
don't I don't know I don't know assuming
everything's on the board and that we're
following the law are you allowed
legally to go are you allowed to go into
your representative's office and sit
there and refuse to move even after they
try and tell you to leave well it's
trespassing it's it's for sure
trespassing I mean how did you know I
don't know they wanted they wanted more
foreign aid for AIDS medication so
they're trespassing to to make for sure
they were sitting there locking arms
refusing to leave yelling yelling about
Kevin McCarthy I guess the answer is no
it's not legal trespassing it seems
pretty Tresor to me also isn't that some
of the risks of protesting right like if
you're choosing to protest you obviously
know there's a potential that you could
you know be on property or not supposed
to I mean nobody protests from their own
living room right he used to be getting
arrested was good publicity back in the
day it was a good way to get the newspap
J Fonda was getting arrested like every
Friday or whatever it was when she was
doing her CL protest outside of the a
bunch of a bunch of celebrities like to
get arrested when it's environmentalist
related stuff but then we have this
example where it's like we had One
Singular day and now we can never let it
go and again I know this point we all
fetish they fetishized right but where
are the black lives matter protest
arrest right what happens when it
happens you see what happens to them
they get let off they get very short
sentences or they just get let off all
together settlements from the city
settlements from the city yeah we did a
story Hannah Nightingale at post
millennial did a story last week about
the huge uh amount of money that cities
have been paying out to BLM and antifa
militant
activists um compared to how much damage
was done it was like $2 billion in
Insurance damage the most expensive
riots in American history in 2020 and
cities have been paying out millions and
millions of dollars to people for having
arrested them one guy in La got paid out
like millions of dollars for being shot
with a rubber bullet now do you remember
the summer of 2020 it was like you know
defund police you have to use non-lethal
crowd control so they use non-lethal
crowd control and the city still has to
pay out millions of dollars M what the
hell is that because they're not
supposed to be against that narrative
where it's okay to be against whatever
they have demonized anybody who went to
January 6 I mean even when you look at
this now a lot of the mainstream
coverage of it has dropped the fact that
like Trump held a peaceful rally where
he talked and then later said everyone
go home don't go there they just draft
it completely they act like people
randomly showed up in DC to Riot and
that's obviously not what happened but
that's the narrative that they would
like that's the history they would like
to preserve that uh the BLM riers were
just you know peacefully protesting
while the BLM riters the BLM riters were
um uh involved in a public health
emergency remember because racism was a
bigger Public Health Emergency than Co
so true I'm never forgiving the whole Co
thing I'm never getting over that you
think on January 6 there was some
violence obviously people R some people
rioted smashed stuff up
of so ow going was a riot and saying
other side of the building Owen was on
the other side where there were no riots
my understanding is that where Owen was
with Alex Jones it was just people
walking around they were not at the area
where people were smashing and throwing
things at cops and stuff I trespassing I
get it technically I guess I can I can
wrap my mind around it but for him to
say Democrats are tyrants death to kill
them kill the tyrants like is that what
he said that he said these people are
the tyrants Now kill the tyrants that's
kind of
people I I don't disagree to it but the
way you phrase it is a bit unfair he
said he did say Democrats are posing as
Communists but we know they are there's
tyrants death to tyranny death to
tyrants so I agree with what you're
saying but he the way you said it was a
little bit agressive it wasn't um like
an imminent threat to violence he wasn't
calling like I want you to go this name
this person at this place K he wasn't
saying that so it wasn't illegal to say
that but if you say that in front of a
mob and then the mob get get angrier I
mean but it is like a oh won't someone
rid me of this priest right mhm right
but but regardless
uh what's he charged with just
trespassing in which case this is
immaterial to his sentencing you're
right his speech is not relevant right
and uh unless he's charged with making
threats but oh won't someone rid me of
this priest is not illegal the other you
can argue irresponsible but they're
they're doing this because they're also
doing it to Trump like if you look at
the indictment in Georgia it t it it
references tweets that he made like oh
the Georgia ballot counting is being
broadcast on oan and fonnie Willis says
that's evidence of a
conspiracy doesn't make any sense I
think the fact that if you look at the
like hundreds of counts I think the fact
a lot of them are social media posts
that the The Da in in Georgia did not
indict laugher Purdue and Graham shows
it's entirely political to go after
Trump's Administration mhm the grand
jury voted to indict these sitting
members or or at the time these members
of the of of the Senate and uh da didn't
do it why well it doesn't serve her
political purposes in any way the da
could still bring the charges the grand
jury voted to indict right but it looks
like she's just going after the Trump
Administration and his lawyers purely
political well because they want to say
that his campaign was a was a criminal
conspiracy well we saw you saw that post
from Julie Kelly on Twitter that she was
uh I think I don't know she was with
Enrique tario somebody was yeah and
Enrique was saying that they Tri to get
him to claim that take a deal where he
says he was working with Trump or Trump
told him to do it wasn't it Cara cast
NOA at Gateway is that who said that I
saw a tweet from J Kelly talking about
yeah that he was he was apparently told
that when they arrested him say that
Trump you know was working with you he
told me you know he told you to do
something that effect and when he said
no they were like then you're going to
go away for the rest of your life and
they did flip the it worker right at uh
Mara Lago what they threw they flipped
the it worker at marago has now who is
turning on Trump it's really amazing to
me that there are some people who have
families have children and they look at
a burning building and they hear a
little girl scream help and they say I
am going to run that building Lord help
me I will save that little girl knowing
they may die and leave behind their
children to be fatherless and their
wives to be widows but they know what
the right thing is to do and then there
are people who are told
well we'll lock you up you better do as
you're told and they are completely
unwilling to make any degree of
sacrifice or or or stand up for anything
they fall over they fold like cheap
suits thanks for watching this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8:00 pm
and become a member over at timcast.net